hello reject nation it's greg al-baqir
whoa-whoa-whoa-whoa charmita Badshah
Bhattacharya one of my heroes is Conan
O'Brien when I was in eighth grade I
went through depression as a normal life
girl looking and then I would watch
Conan late at night I called it my combs
own medication I will and I will for the
longest time I wanted to see Tom Cruise
be interviewed on Conan and now there's
this video alcohol Conan drives with Tom
Cruise the second this got sent over to
me I was like absolutely I will gladly
watch this it's gonna be worth it are
you ready to show me okay
Conan O'Brien here and I'm in London and
I'm in a car it's outfitted with cameras
and about to meet a pretty big star are
we gonna do it we're gonna do carpool
Coffee we're gonna go eat coffee ready
to talk about common medians in car a
[Laughter]
genius genius that's this thing we don't
do that okay what because if it's
someone else's thing you can't do that
you don't want to do it it's out
yeah check this out okay we're gonna
blow up the internet you want to blow up
the Internet yes I was blowing up about
the Internet I'm gonna do it he's happy
alright everyone else has done the car
okay fun yeah but okay my culture but my
bedtime
yeah as my thing is we take it back to
basics okay
amazing dry little I am have you never
driven
so this is new to me okay
you feel you feel okay about this
getting these pretty good I didn't
really sleep since I got off the plane
here we go guys okay so it's ice watch
that person up there just just watch
this guy right here
I'm happy to answer questions
I got american-made coming out sorry
movie never really liked to move thank
you
it's really good thank you very much
told me a story once Jack Nicholson
doesn't told a story yet I'm here he
said you know really don't tell anyone
but I I feel like maybe now it's okay if
I could you think I'm sorry again this
friend about Steve get through these
roundabouts just chill down especially
on that dick other side so you just keep
that story for later yeah oh god Dave
his attempts
it's a refinery over there a Battersea
it's back there if I wanted a tour guide
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I didn't imagine this much traffic and I
didn't imagine that in a way you don't
want to think of traffic and raining
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
you're slightly in the bike lane yeah
looks like it back but it's not on the
hawk which bike I was over here I'll
worry about it
yeah summaries was also locked I got a
question you guys let's do it okay
Turner gentlemen did you get along with
Debra Winger is she someone who because
the chemistry felt good but I couldn't
tell if that was just asking really well
you carry her into the fact recovery
you're worried much you know what yeah
they're wearing the naval uniform and
you carry her through the side too
yeah Oh
[Laughter]
videos made me so happy
Oh
you stuff about 45-minutes you were out
hard we're just getting started I'm good
all tanks empty it also looks a little
used it's just
[Laughter]
no a lot of questions
No
[Laughter]
okay seriously how about three and a
half hours I couldn't totally fine I
could not live with myself now I would
not be able to live with myself you know
okay what is that button like that
button right there that what is the one
[Laughter]
you had on one okay that was Tom Cruise
movies American made
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow that was super unexpected yeah but
you had the chance to spend three hours
with Tom Cruise what would you do that
there's my soon silence to Tom Cruise
for the next three hours I'm just trying
to smell you for the longest time I've
wondered it is I've never come across an
interview with Conan and Tom Cruise and
he's said there that I'm gonna meet a
celebrity any me Tom Cruise I feel like
there must be more than one person like
me who's wanted Conan to interview Tom
Cruise or do a special video segment
with Tom Cruise
I love sketches where you can feel the
writers room being like you know will be
funny
people are gonna expect some big thing
man that was hilariously awkward I'm
really into it I love about Tom Cruise
just a game it's game for anything
random like that promoters will be in no
other way other than the fact that he's
willing to have some fun you don't often
see him in that light
yeah having fun yeah so it was like
refreshingly great to see that I hear
the greatest things about Tom Cruise
every interview you see on the internet
everyone raves lovingly things about him
and the few people I've met that I've
actually gotten to meet him or spend a
little bit of time with him when he's
talking with you he makes you sort of
feel like you're the only one in the
room it's like a common thing I've ever
even said like he makes eye contact with
you he's invested in the conversation at
all times
I once saw a whole video called the
charisma of Tom Cruise and I've taken
some of those tips but I'm terrible out
of fly I would agree to that yeah you
agree I'm terrible at applying the Tom
Cruise tips
whatever jeez sure made that I haven't
made fun of you once when he talks he
looks at you right in the eye any and
they said that when he listens that's
where I got it from
you gotta apply anything you weight in a
book od listens his mouth is slightly
open like if you notice in the whole
video like it's slightly open showing a
relaxed lip and he's engaged in
conversation
don't awkwardly look at my literally
doing it right now you have this great
like judgmental look thank you I love it
oh my god I love that yeah it's good
constantly yeah just look at me like
every time I feel looking at man I've
noticed you're like listening I always
feel like you're thinking I'm an idiot I
think it's fantastic it has created no
tension in my shoulders whatsoever
do you like Tom Cruise thank you do you
think he's handsome oh wow
wow you're blushing I mean I'm doctors
asking you do you like doctor I probably
more nervous to meet Conan O'Brien
yeah well I would be afraid to meet him
because I'm I would be like what is he
gonna do to me makes me sound like a
predator no like him and Ellen I feel
like they both do this thing we're like
you don't know what's gonna surprise you
or what weird thing it's really involved
in that's fair I feel like with Tom
Cruise though I would be more
comfortable there just engage in
conversation with him Conan I would feel
a pressure to make him laugh that I'd be
thinking too much about the jokes I'm
making and if I'm not making laugh that
I'm gonna hate myself I'd rather meet
Tom Cruise because it'd be way more
comfortable I think I would want to meet
Conan because that would mean I made it
job means nothing you can meet Tom
Cruise at like an event that's a good
event but if he's interviewing you Oh or
imagine being interviewed by stalkers
first Tom Cruise interview ever
that would
crazy good man you see Conan has my
exact sense of humor because this is
exactly what I would do as a bit I feel
like you know there's James core like
all the sufferers making fun of
comedians and cars James Corden I would
be that guy in the room being like it
would be so funny if we did absolutely
sit with doctors yeah Conan your mic own
bone medication
I mean cones own medication well guys
thanks for sending that my way that was
a delight that really cheered up my
night after a horrible evening I have
was from me that this entire time I
finally feel better and have restored my
faith in humanity and what is good not
for long because once the camera cuts
it's more shemitah subscriber the real
reason I like that notification bell and
follow
charmita Blackbeard bhattacharya I can
sound it out if I see it in front of me
it says here on your Instagram you're an
actress model dancer and the silly goose
how are you a silly goose none of your
photos represents silly goose you like
Union watch that video this one that's a
silly person well you have proven me
wrong